-Making their TV debut as Rusty,
performing
"Surrender to the Rhythm"
from their album
"The Resurrection of Rust,"
here is Elvis Costello
and Allan Mayes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Well, they danced to every
tune the band could play ♪
♪♪
♪ At just about midnight,
they decided to call it a day ♪
♪♪
♪ But there's one thing that's
left here on their minds ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah, yeah ♪
-♪ To get a little rice ♪
♪ At any price ♪
♪ They stole
the shoes and rice ♪
♪ Surrendered to the rhythm
that is calling them home ♪
-Whoo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Well, he was dumb, he was
dirty, but she was a princess ♪
♪ Custom-made it
to fit right into his arms ♪
♪♪
♪ She could thrill him,
she could chill him ♪
-♪ Whoo, down to the bone ♪
♪ But he was in his teens ♪
♪ Had to spill the beans ♪
♪ Still looking
for ways and means ♪
♪ Surrender to the rhythm
that is calling him home ♪
-♪ Well, who's to say
if it's right or wrong? ♪
-♪ Not another singer
in another song ♪
Whoo!
♪♪
Yeah!
♪ Whoa, we're doing alright ♪
-♪ We're doing alright ♪
-♪ Yeah, we're doing okay ♪
-♪ We're doing okay ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Well, now guess what,
guess what happened ♪
♪ Guess what happened next ♪
♪♪
-♪ She had to go ♪
♪ Said she was meeting up
with one of her friends ♪
-♪ But it was
nothing more or less
♪ Than another
mess of the blues ♪
-♪ But he had more to lose ♪
♪ Started putting in clues ♪
♪ Oh, yeah, paying his dues ♪
-♪ Surrender to the rhythm
that is calling him home ♪
♪ Surrender to the rhythm ♪
♪ Surrender, yeah,
to the rhythm ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ Surrender to the rhythm ♪
♪ Surrender, yeah,
to the rhythm ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Oh!